[Musique]
ouais c'est pas donné mais elle est
géniale
ouais t'as l'habitude avec les pick up
en bottines gibson ou non je suis désolé
je joue pas c'est pour les 50 ans de mon
père
or la chance l'a vite ma soeur on a eu
pas renié et ton père sera ravie de
silom banking ça déménage chez fou tu
peux me croire
excusez moi j'adore quel genre de
musique qui fait on perd je dirais que
c'est des gens gaz et eau c'est une
excellente guitare de jazz pat metheny
performe avec ça je pense que c'est la
meilleure guitare qui existait alors ils
jouent du métier ni délit est
probablement le meilleur guitariste
fusion de tous les temps ces genres de
jekyll idée guitariste fusion content
est ce que toi tu es dans la fusion ça
aussi je sais pas ce qui c'est c'est
juste que je demandais sa suivi taris
fusion ou et puis j'étais même moi aussi
je suis dans la fusion jean sango jeune
je travaille tout un tas de jeunes je
veux dire écoutez le dans vos pairs ok
c'est sûr c'est génial
ouais alors tandis que je me demandais
s'il y avait d'autres couleurs couleurs
tu parles des finitions leur finition
question qu'on doit d'autre part et on a
une seule peur ce qui est magnifique
moi j'en une à l'arrière là bas non
japon réduit qu'est fils car c'est cool
très cool et moi je peux aller chercher
les tuer le père
puis le marché
[Musique]
riche d'enseignements
nous réfléchissons
[Musique]
gym à rennes vendredi
si je termine ma part
[Musique]
oui la nuit
jje de feu scandaient mam
tu as
là
ouais
[Musique]
prise d'antenne
je
bizarre
[Musique]
sans doute
jz m'appeler ont vu
aurélien gizzi au bénin
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si je verrai
m
tu devrais venir ce soir tous les
cocktails à moitié prix durant le match
qui me fait jamais payé de toute façon
le sait alors passe ouais t'as raison
fut l'action est rare chez moi alors je
devrais y aller
qu'est-ce qui a inspecté femme est
ailleurs non ça fait juste un mois que
j'ai pas baiser
et
la liste viol par le centre d'emploi moi
aussi thyssen j'ai commencé sur la ligne
d'assemblage est juste tout y est mais
j'étais meilleur une journée quand tu
perds tu peux me croire je suis le
meilleur tri hier ici ouais mais
peut-être que d'ici un an je serai
responsable de section et à toute la
gare de ça le nouveau gars il ralentit
la cadence et c'est pas mon travail de
lui dire qui ralentit la cadence et mon
groupe you vendredi soir est-ce que ça
t'intéresse une musique qui fait pas
juste graisser les oreilles et toi quel
genre de musique techno rock boxing
t'adore à ça et l'entrée gratuite pour
les filles alors vient pas tout seul
l'effectif y est bien genre à cela la
détention de rien fermé en question qui
arrête là l'île s'ils ne font pas leur
travail pas pourquoi je ferais bien
ouais je dois être à la maison avant 8
heures sinon il met son pantalon de
jogging
une fois qu'elle a mis son pantalon de
jogging j'ai droit à rien tu comprends
c'est fermé
qu'est ce que tu fais qu'est ce que tu
fais là
hector est nouveau ok il lui faudra
encore quelques jours vous devez tous
être patient step tu devrais être
capable de gérer ces situations si tu
est responsable de section exact oui
parfait alors nettoyer tout ça ok
ensuite on roule aujourd'hui on peut pas
se permettre de retard aller au travail
et entendit ça tu vois un site toujours
donné de foot sinon on dirait une bande
de gamins je me sens vraiment comme une
gardienne d'enfants
désolé j'ai arrêté la pièce ce matin je
montre aux grands génies comment bien
chargé l'élévateur lagarde
c'est toute sa carrière conduire un
chariot élévateur et même si c'est pas
le faire il fait partie d'un groupe de
musique non ouais tu parles pas je suis
sûr qu'il doit jouer que me conduit
c'est lé batteur ensuite einstein marie
non l'autre côté drôle de visage elle
m'a demandé peu non réclamé plus de
jours de congé aussi sec
je lui dis peut-être bien s'il finissait
par écrire sa carte de temps comme il
faut alors oui je lui donnerai peut-être
plus de journée t'inquiète fais moi
confiance jamais l'écrira comme il faut
sa carte de temps prévient je dois y
aller je dois battre cet échéancier de
pantalon jogging débiteur
[Musique]
merde ne te retourne pas tu m'as vu
aucune marche jusqu'à ta maison et en
chinois
ok ouais
mais je rêve c'est une chance que j'ai
là tout va bien
j'ai pas le temps de parler tout de
suite net ouais t'es bien l'occuper moi
et je suis très très occupé et puis
c'est pire encore je dois aller passer
un coup de téléphone au bureau avant que
tout le monde soit parti ouais
écoutez je vais pas de retenir trop
longtemps mais où est ce que vous serez
en novembre le 17 le 17 et bien tu as
dit le 17 on se rendort de la ville ah
oui ou est-ce que vous allez et une
minute
moi je voulais dire le set dans ce cas
aucun doute vous servir génial à chaque
année on assiste à ce dîner leslie et
moi on y va toujours avec le rotary club
c'est un dîner de charité et on s'y
amuse beaucoup et on adorait vous
invitez toi issue si vous seriez les
inviter à notre table m'étonne je crois
que c'est quelque chose qui nous
intéresse pas du tout ah oui pourquoi
c'est très amusant je sais pas suzie
déteste tous ces gens du dîner pourquoi
ça elle nie connaître à personne n'est
elle se sentira très mal au c rien dans
ce genre là sur salaire non et ne se
sentira pas mal à l'aise c'est pas
cérémonieux je t'assure c'est juste un
durieux groupe d'amis écoute écoute ça
je crois que j'ai une excellente idée
je vais acheter les billets aujourd'hui
sinon je suis sûr qu'ils s'envoleront
toi tu parles à suzy et tu vois ce
qu'elle en dit peut-être même que leslie
lui téléphonera mais tu sais ce que
c'est quand les femmes jose entre elles
j'étais entendons ne parlerai plus tard
doit dépasser ce coup de fil
désolé j'allais j'ai presque oublier les
billets sont 40 $ le couvert je sais
c'est exorbitant mais la nourriture et
fins statistiques ça fait 80 dollars en
tout y'a pas tu n'as que je dois rentrer
tout de suite passé ce coup de téléphone
alors il compte on pourra s'en reparler
plus tard qu'elle encaisse et ça et joël
si jamais tu veux qu'on surveille chez
toi quand tu seras en voyage soit le
hockey
j'apprécie ce genre de hockey ou est-ce
que vous allez au juste on s'en va quand
leslie et moi je te jure on adorait ça
allait en vacances avec vous c'est vrai
je dois vraiment y aller
ok dans ce cas c'est très gentil net
années merci encore risque est inverse
seuil
une dernière chose est jeune
salut merde j'en peux plus de ce n'était
de caisse qui parle
agissez qu'elle emmerdeur et sa femme
est encore pire
je me demande combien de temps il serait
capable de parler si on le sait rien et
moi j'ai maintenant la trouille de
sortir devant la maison parce que j'ai
par qu'il fuit nous avons tout dit ou
bien notre monde où on sortait dehors et
on entrait par le garage n'avait jamais
personne qui nous guettait ont marché
jusqu'à l'épicerie on se foutait des
plombiers des garçons piscine en parlant
de ça on doit engager à nouveau garçon
piscine le niveau du chlore c'est un
vrai désert désole c'est que notre
nouvelle essence de vanille artificielle
est beaucoup plus intense qu'on le
croyait ce qui veut dire que les
nouveaux biscuits à la crème sur
lesquels on travaille en excellente
chance de marcher je dois le mettre au
point avant web le driver et si ça
marche alors il se pourrait bien qu'on
vante la compagnie
tu te rappelles ya longtemps c'est toi
qui as fait le design de mon tout
premier biscuit à la crème il est encore
encadré dans mon bureau
et là j'ai dessine des coupons au moins
ma créativité est satisfaite que la
tuque on gagne dans la chambre tous les
deux au nom suis fatigué ouais c'est bah
j'en sais rien c'est milieu de la
semaine
on ne sait pas le milieu de la semaine
c'est lundi mangera merde s'il indiquait
ce qui se passe c'est mon émission
ah c'est aujourd'hui je dois acheter une
maison qui a pas la salle de bains
adossé au mur de la télévision et
pourquoi ça lorsque c'est dur d'éjaculer
quant à la télé qu'ils veulent à travers
le meilleur des cas choisir des deux
autres salles de bain bien trop louche
parce qu'on utilise qu'une salle de bal
je mettrai un peu de la nasa
nourrissante insonorisation n'a pas du
tout aimé trop fibre de verre dans des
murs parce que la masturbation tout fait
aux jo elle qui doit prendre des
responsabilités et de dégorger le
poireau quand tu veux et où tu veux dans
toute la grande maison
c'est un propre maison c'est ton propre
business écoutait et barmal ici
maintenant regarde que tu as je sais
même où quoi quoi quoi qu'est-ce que
j'ai un ok c'est une prison j'ai je
travaille tout le temps
qu'est ce que ça me donne tout le monde
s'en balancent des essences regarde la
femme l'homme le gars avec un groupe de
merde je suis sûr qu'ils baissent plus
que my way
probablement qu'il vit dans un
appartement de merde je déménagerai tout
de suite dans un appartement de merde si
la salle de bain n'est pas côté de la
télé
elle appartenait à mon père il est mort
le mois passé on a tout plein de compte
payer et c'est vraiment très difficile
pour moi vous savez lui il adorait la
fusion tu sais quoi je devrais pas dire
ça mais étant donné les circonstances
tu devrais aller au magasin de musique
tu auras beaucoup plus que ce que je te
donne non ça va aller tout ce que je
veux c'est que ce soit fini une fois
pour toutes ce qu'on prend ce qu'on
prend à temps et je veux et je vais te
donner un petit extra tiens prends ça
non non non non non non et que doazit et
par le ce a déjà été assez dur comme ça
pour toi
[Musique]
c'est mon sentiment de sa taille et
est-ce qu'on songe toujours à la
remplacer par un robot elle ouais mais
on n'aurait peut-être pas à faire tu me
croiras peut-être pas mais tu te
rappelles de michael janet olten de
general mills qui avait appelé qui
disait qu'il pensait peut-être acheter
ouais t'as dit qu'il n'était plus
intéressé que c'était juste de la
surenchère est mais là il est sérieux et
bien nous faire une offre
je pars d'une vraie au festi turinois ça
doit faire partie d'une plus grosse
stratégie économique parce que c'est au
dessus de la valeur du marché je crois
[Musique]
ouah
je vais peut-être enfin capable de
liquider tout ça me retirer il y aura
toutefois pas de détails réglés mais je
crois que c'est super et il a dit qu'il
rappellerait dans une semaine
qu'est-ce que je dois lui dire
tu lui dis oui c'est sûr
[Musique]
pendant qu encore
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais d'accord alors appel 6 à autre
chose
il en a perdu une c'est certain l'autre
ils vont tenter de la rattacher war
c'est atroce ce truc je comprends rien à
cette histoire notre historique en
matière de sécurité sans tache et ans
conforme à tous les standards
je crois que c'est juste un un accident
domestique
t'es sûrement assuré pour sa voile et je
crois qu'il obtiendra un très gros
montants je souhaite que tous parlent de
couilles et je pense aussi à notre
fragilité et spécialement alain couilles
qui sont là dans leur petit sac à chaque
minute
on pourrait les pertes pour toujours que
serait la vie sur lesquels à son
testicule
t'imagines satwa écoute pour tout dire
il est rare que j'utilise mes coups dans
ce mobilier et l'autre soir je pensais
que tu t'en foutrais une devant son
émission c'est suzy et moi on couche
ensemble peut-être une fois aux trois
mois alors écoute les frustrations
sexuelles c'est très dur mais j'ai
peut-être une solution
quoi tu devrais prendre du xanax du
xanax c'est pas pour l'anxiété ça c'est
bon pour tous les désordres d'ordre
psychologique du dsm iv xanax par son
action de fait sentir heureux c'est
pourquoi ça fonctionne tout le temps et
coachant laval quand j'ai mal à la tête
aussi
je suis certain que ça devrait marcher
pour toutes les frustrations sexuelles
donc je vais en chercher oh non il ya
autre chose d'excellent le sirop à la
codéine
pourquoi c'est génial c'est tout
un travailleur de schering d'extras
blessés au bas ventre gros
dédommagements un million de dollars
plus de testicules 1 millions $ puis de
testicules un million un million pull
testicules dans le stade pour qui ce nom
dans nous et qu'une seule tête wilkins
un moment je voudrais l'adresse merci
[Musique]
les gars de chez lui l'a remis aux
enfants de cet incident testiculaire et
s'inquiète système peut obtenir plus que
ce que l'assurance vie offre et bien ça
ça pourrait nous handicaper je dirai
comment il va se taire en ce moment bien
il sort de l'hôpital aujourd'hui il a
dit qu'il ne voulait pas nous
poursuivent alors c'est sûr nous
inquiéter il dit qu'il ne veut pas plus
que ce qu'on lui offre et que ce qui est
correct est correct je le trouve bien
calme à propos de ça ouais quand tu
perds des couilles ben ça doit te calmer
un peu je t'ai dit qu'il voulait avoir
une augmentation aujourd'hui qu'est
einstein pas vrai bryant appelle tout le
monde ici einstein
j'ignore de qui tu parles einstein sur
l'élévateur 1 je croyais que c'était le
petit génie ah oui c'est vrai eh bien
les petits génies voulait une
augmentation noté dit tuez moi d'après
ce que tu es un gars l'autre jour et il
a tenté de mettre ça sur le dos de
nstein tu devrais vraiment essayé
d'apprendre le nom des employés
ouais j'y ai pensé mais ensuite je me
suis dit si on a une entente dans une
semaine j'aurai pas à le faire c'est pas
comme si j'allais vite et einstein le
petit génie du resto chic aux jo elle je
peux te présenter les nouveaux
temporaire des doubles et rencontrer
joël voici cd
salut fanny et voici h
désolé comment tu t'appelles victor
victor ouais ouais
yann est ok
[Musique]
salut salut je suis désolé mais c'est
donc à vous toutes ces grandes
entreprises
oui vous l'avez parti c'est vous qu'elle
avait créée ouais on peut dire ça ça
alors comment juste bien ça t'intéresse
vraiment d'habitude hier dormant non
vraiment je veux savoir
oui je me disais avez vous inventez des
essences ou bien ouais ça souvent ma
mère nous faisait la merde on faisait de
délicieux biscuits à la racine athée je
trouvais que la pâte avant que la crise
était meilleur que le biscuit lui même
je me suis dit pourquoi et j'ai constaté
qu'une partie de la saveur de l'essence
s'évaporer lors de la cuisson
et lorsque j'étais à l'université en
chimie j'ai trouvé une façon d'utiliser
une sorte de dérivé synthétique du thé
des bois
surprise ils avaient un taux
d'évaporation dérisoire et partant de là
tout ça alors vous avez découvert tout
ça tout seul genre avec votre tête
moi alors vous devez être super riches
j'ai eu une série cette bmw je porte
vous allez vous connaissez tellement
personne aussi vous êtes vraiment
populaire c'est très mignon c'est que
vos six ont l'air d'être des huit à
moins que ce soit vos huit qui ont l'air
de vos six lieux sept dirait d'aller
frapper des balles des je te présente
six mois là mais quelle surprise moi
c'est dix entrepreneurs spiritualiste
guérissent hockey fut enchanté et moi
aussi alors investir et nice mais
bienvenu chez nous on s'en va jouer au
golf mais on pourrait aussi aller faire
un tour ailleurs et vieux
est-ce qu'elle travaille ici prêt pour
un bout de temps quoi tu passe du bon
temps
un bout de temps et de grâce à l'aide de
la regarder en lève toi de là
j'adore ça j'adore ton style gelé pas
engagée elle est arrivée par le centre
d'emploi ils l'ont envoyée ici comme
tous les autres le centre d'emploi va
falloir que je les appelle du ségala ya
jamais eu une femme aussi canon qui a
bossé ici mais tu céline c'est normal
les canaux ou s'ils ont besoin de
travail qui croit vraiment la plupart de
tes temporaires ont l'air d'yves rome
n'était pas d'accord et sont des gars tu
veux entendre quelque chose de bizarre
mais je crois qu'elle flirtait avec moi
tu crois ça j'ai peut-être dans les
renom et pourquoi pas mieux
je crois bien que tu peux avoir
n'importe laquelle des filles qui sont
là pas qu'à choisir celles avec la
riziculture un coup c'est sûr j'en suis
pas certain et mais je te dis moi tu es
le roi de tous domaines ses tons pâles
asturies si tu es le roi de sais c'est
quoi encore ce que tu fais ils sont
faits des essences et et puis les
essences en est érodée le seigneur des
et 100 types et les femmes en bas elle
le sentent et tu peux les avoir si ça
t'intéresse tant qu'à moi je passe mon
tour aucune d'entre elles matière mais
tu sais la fille qui étaient là ce
serait excellent pour toi ou encore
[Rires]
marie je sois d'accord d'accord
tous avaient dans des tasses ou tu sais
c'est qu'on a fait parce qu'il met place
tout va le point il est en pire c'est un
patchwork multicolore avec une doublure
turquoise avec un titre sans drogue qui
portent à qui tu
[Musique]
mais
d
tu es
[Musique]
mérité
m
là
l'hépatite et petit à petit
[Musique]
passez devant moi si c'est tout ce qui
est vraiment dans le style c'est très
gentil de ta pas très gentil j'arrive
pas à droite et accepte d essence
reynolds c'est parce que je travaille à
lézinnes ah ouais je travaille là aussi
je suis sérieux ouais sérieux avant il
ya tout juste de commencer
j'ai le plus rapide frayeur d'illizi
vraiment away jarente palette la journée
les allées faire de moi un responsable
de section
je m'appelle sine die
[Musique]
on ne fait plus jamais jamais je sais
plus quoi faire
on lui en train de devenir comme ces
couples de frères et soeurs vous avez un
air de famille tu dis n'importe quoi ok
et pour aggraver les choses
j'ai toujours cette cette cindy en tête
j'y pense beaucoup
est ce que j'aurai souvent la chance de
rencontrer une fille aussi canon qui
s'intéresse aux essences tu vois c'est
que je t'ai dit qu'il m'a presque
demandé à sortir je te jure elle m'a
donné son numéro de téléphone et elle
m'a demandé si j'allais à la fête tout
le groupe de rory va jouer na waie qui
fera quoi alors qu'est ce que je ferais
rien du tout tu crois que j'aurais une
aventure dans d'autres fusils je vais
plutôt endurer jusqu'à ce que je sois
trop vieux qui ça ne lève plus ensuite
ça ira bien
ici c'était suzy qui est de jouer dans
le dos moi franchement écoute joie et je
me suis dit tu comprends et j'ai rien
contre elle mais si elles vivaient la
même chose que tu vis
si elle ne trompaient ça ne dérangerait
j'ai inséré le courage
non je crois que non au point où j'en
suis c'est bizarre mais oui un peu mais
est ce que le ferais tu crois quoi une
tromperie sur écoute j'en sais rien je
c'est possible si possible elle pourrait
être tentée je pense et un apollon un
genre d'adonis la drague et alors ce que
tu dis c'est qu'elle elle irait jusqu'à
te tromper si la tentation se présentait
et toi la tentation se présente est une
feria du tout c'est ça ok j'ai une
solution
écoute je veux pas de drogue il existe
des recettes anciennes qui nous viennent
des aztèques mais pour faire en sorte
que ta femme te trompes
si c'est ce que tu désires tu t'es que
tu es engage un gigolo pour qu'ils aient
une aventure avec ta femme
je suis sérieux je connais un gars tu
connais un gigolo
oui je te suivre quand ça se fait que tu
connais j2me s'appelle ghorab braderie
de louis il est toujours rendu ici c'est
un ami de cliff tangage brad
il a une aventure avec ce musée ok mais
d'appliquer ans qui veulent les
consommations vieux tu dis hein juste de
me dire que ça ne dérangerait pas s'il
avait eu la voiture avec deux cas et
c'est jamais te trompes alors toi qui
n'a surtout pas se sentir coupable d'y
aller avec cindy tout les problèmes sont
résolus
quel éclair de génie j'ai eu tu trouves
pas être un bon ça je vais finir par te
prendrais xanax c'est sérieux tu veux
savoir ce que je vais faire je vais
asseoir suzy je vais lui parler de tout
ça comme on fait normalement mais non je
rigolais pas de la rigolade
je rigolais je suis sérieux et là tu me
fiche la paix rappelle moi ce que ça
fait ce truc là ouais moi je crois qu
est ce qui est correct est correct c'est
vrai respect et sticks aurec pour toi
c'est d'envoyer un message pour qu'un
horrible accident dans ce genre ne
puissent jamais plus arrivé à d'autres
c'est pour ça que jeune avocat pour toi
tu veux savoir c'est qui que le gars
qu'on voit aux arrêts de bus tu vois tu
y joueras clair tu m'as idiot at leur
oui tu es trop bonne avec moi cd
ok ce thème je suis désolé est en train
de m'exciter moi je vais t'exciter étant
docteur a dit qu'il était très
importante qui n'excite pas avant la fin
des audiences
c'était le cas sur suis désolé je suis
désolé je crois qu'on devrait y aller je
suis désolé tu as vu tous ces canards
j'aurais dû apporter ma carabine merde
tu te rappelles la couleur de la pilule
que je t'ai donné quoi merde je crois
pas que c'était nous un axe ça pourrait
être plus ritalin spécial ça fait rien
c'est quand même le special k c'est un
tranquillisant pour les chevaux qui
parfois des effets bizarre sur les
humains horaires pour s'inquiéter qui
ferait mieux d'arrêter de boire
tu te rappelles est ce que tu me disais
l'histoire du gigolo way est ce qu'ils
croient pas que c'est que c'est mal tu
crois pas que c'est pas très morale
qu'est ce qui serait pas morale là dans
le prétoire
eudeline heures écoute moi si elle veut
pas le faire
elle n'a pas à le faire ok et s'il le
fait ce sera elle qui aura péché est
alors toi tu auras le droit d'aller
fourni quéau tu voudras et quand tu
voulais et c'est ça qui est moralement
juste 12 grocam y a rien là dedans que
la morale réprouve et tu disais que
c'est un ami à toi alors comment il
s'appelle brad tu veux du téléphone peut
être attendent insee fait vraiment trop
bizarre de parler de ça écoute à rien
qu'à lui dire que c'est lui qui s'occupe
de la piscine pour l'été et tu verras ce
qui se passe c'est sérieux
si elle ne fait rien alors ce sera
génial et tu te sentiras mieux parce que
tu ne le rates pas trompé
de toute façon il nous faut un nouveau
garçon de piscine fait c'est ainsi nous
avons c'est juste que je sais rien c'est
trop cinglé on doit écouter l'univers
allez quoi un ou deux verres maintenant
si je téléphonais à brad il me dira ce
qu'il en pense - vas-y alors je pense
que c'est on ne peut plus clair c'est ça
c'est 200 dollars c'est ça ouais 200 oui
mais moi je prends mon 10%
quoi voyant qu est ce qui est dit et
entremetteur maintenant non je crois que
c'est pas le mot quand c'est un
prostitué mâle d'accord y'a nous tenons
pour ça c'est pas un souteneur mais
c'est peu dans ce genre là je pense pas
c'est moi qui ai tout organisé j'ai
saisi non plus n'a pas tant fait parce
qu'il paiera de sa poche
ok ça va donc ses 200 $ ou 1 220 terrine
quoi j'ai une petite question
ouais vous allez regarder c'est bien ça
non non non non je non moi je serais
même pas là je serai au travail tu te
rappelles en arabe on a discuté tout ça
et écoute encore une fois alors tu vas
aller à la maison de joël et tu diras
que tu le nouveau garçon piscine c'est
pas trop compliqué et ça une fois sur
place je vais simplement tenter de
séduire sa femme si elle ne répond pas d
avance tu va brosser la piscine et
quitter ses taux y a pas plus simple
donc vous serrez et c'est vrai pas de
toucher le cul
écoutez et il il sera au travail
toi tu ira là-bas lorsqu'il sera
ailleurs et toi tu fera semblant d'être
le garçon de piscine qui essaie de
séduire les pousse au sein ouais j'ai
saisi ça coule donc vous serez là non il
sera papa là ne sera pas la maison toi
tu seras à la maison la femme sera la
maison et lui il se moque pas la saison
1 cuil
aucun problème ça ça va être chaud
nourrit pas il est possible que refusent
les annonces shin'en oui non j'ai
tellement hâte et se peut qu'elle refuse
chirurgie en v1
si vous connaissez d'autres personnes
qui pourraient être intéressés parce
qu'il ya tout un tas dé pouce qui
s'ennuient est ce que vous leur parlerez
moi parce que je me dis si je peux en
trouver assez peut-être que je pourrai
lâché mon ancien club ce serait génial
parce que je déteste être un paysagiste
j'adore ça a baisé et je suis doué et
moi je vois toujours toutes sortes de
femmes au foyer en chaleur au club alors
ce que je dis c'est si votre femme est
d'accord s'est fixé à dax
tu sais à quoi d'autre je pense à une
autre fois brat ok bon lui mais c'est
cool mais laisse-moi cramer chez toi
t'es pas en état de conduire
na je le sais tu crois qu'il fait à
faire ce bien sûr il est cool c'est
juste un peu trop chauffer le cerveau si
juste qu'il n'a pas l'air trop prier
quand même puisque tu espérais c'est un
gigolo
[Musique]
hu on dirait que ça a été une de ces
soirées
vous auriez pu inviter
[Musique]
alors est elle chantait les dix 10 mois
est-ce que j'ai rêvé hier soir parce
qu'on est taille de la map que cette
histoire déchirure à ce que je sache
est ce que tu peux rejoindre le gaz
c'est quoi sont encore brad ok oui je
peux faire ça je l'appelle il a pas s'en
faire taka lui dire de palais chez moi
qu'est ce que c'est excitant
ok merci pour la drogue il écoute j'ai
passé coord mais de quoi tu parles tu
l'as pays reçoit rennes et j'ai eu son
numéro par cliff klifa pas de téléphone
c'est ainsi mais quel [ __ ]
alors c'est brad qui j'appellerais la
formation je me souviens passé mexique
est en tout cas mexique a tu rigoles
digne quoi le gars est blond aux yeux
bleus tu te fous de ma gueule
oui j'avoue c'est étrange un gars qui a
l'air de seuils qui a un nom mexicain
j'essaye je ne suis pas pour autant je
crois que c'est lopez ou sam chess aux
gouttières s ok j je dois arriver avant
lui j'aurais voudrait qu'on ce paramètre
non c'est tout genre longtemps si les
moeurs des impôts leur ça consomme
hockey bref j'avais brad chavez voulait
que je prenne le message non non c'est
le garçon piscine
tu ferais mieux d'aller rendre alors
est-ce que c'est joël c'est moi elle
jouait ses bras mission accomplie ça a
marché
quoi
écoute tu aurais même pas dû être là
avant au moins encore 45 minutes
oh ouais si vous avez dit des tas de
choses alors j'ai oublié leur alors
ensuite vous là vous avez ouais ça a été
facile
un facile et qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça oh non non pas dans le sens de facile
dans ce genre facile comme ça juste
petit trop dur oubliez ça dis-moi
dis-moi ce qui s'est passé je veux tout
savoir c'est sûr oui je suis sur ok
alors elle m'a dit d'entrée alors je
suis passé en arrière si j'étais un vrai
garçon piscine même si je n'avais pas du
tout quoi faire alors j'ai fait semblant
elle était en maillot de bain voix
j'ai engagé la conversation votre maison
est très jolie merci
c'est votre papa non c'est la nôtre aux
voix
vous avez l'air
six jeunes vivent dans un si joli maison
[Musique]
j'avais un écran solaire
j'ai oublié le lien
bien sûr
j'ai trouvé que c'était assez brillant
de ma part de me demander quand solaire
parce que comme ça je au lieu de juste
lui demander s'il voulait que je lui
frotte au dos était pas pour ça donc
une fois que j'ai commencé à lui frotter
le corps reste est venu tout seul
d'accord ac j'ai compris jean rien
entendu suffisamment ok ok alors
attendez si vous avez d'autres
connaissances que vous voulez que je me
tape
si vous voulez que je me tape votre
femme encore et gk je dois y aller ça
lui bah comment ça va très prochainement
je vais pas trop tenir bien longtemps
j'ai un pris les devants et acheter les
billets du dîner dont on a parlé du
trapel le set
je crois avoir dit qu'ils étaient 40 $
l'assiette non eh bien ils sont rendus
un peu plus cher 55 oui je t'ai dit
qu'on voulait pas y aller à ce dîner tu
te rappelles de ça oui je sais tu m'as
dit qu suzy se sentait mal à l'aise mais
je te le dis elle sera pas mal à l'aise
du tout et n'a droit se mettre en
pantalon de jogging si c'est ça la
solution et c'est sans cérémonie aucune
c'est pas ça le problème donc porte
jamais de rock ta femme
je dois y aller une dernière chose
j'ai eu des mots sait jamais mais je me
disais que tu es bien qu'on pourrait
aller en vacances juste toi et moi on a
fait ça ya très longtemps mais en plus
les tarifs sont réduits sur les caraïbes
je déteste le careï oui pourquoi
c'est chiant ok mais je croyais que tu
adorais m t shirt sous le chaud soleil
je me sens pas très bien je vais me
coucher c'est la nourriture
tu vois moi je fais partie de ce groupe
mais quand qu'en fait c'est les mêmes
quatre cartes pâquerettes
c'est pareil mais c'est plus racheter la
roulette voix et quand quatre c'est plus
genre métal mélodique donc ces cinq
groupes mer
c'est quelqu'un de gauche elle est trop
charmant que ce qu'ils ont cassé les
envoyer la roja
il travaille encore ici du syndic ci
vient a perdu son porte-monnaie le froid
vent lui abonnés et qui est sorti en
dernier des vestiaires être à vous avez
entendu la rumeur
jim dick joël et brian vont de la
compagnie établie la même chose de la
vie qu'ils vont peut-être faire des
millions milliard de dollars aussi tu te
foudre travail comme un [ __ ] juste
pour que ramasse travaille plus fort que
n'importe qui cite additionne tous à
l'âge élevé plus débile vivre pendant la
semaine on doit vraiment faire quelque
chose négative pour les filles mais pas
tout seul
tu as une seconde on a peut-être un gros
problème juniors ce qui se passe mais
tout à coup ce samedi qu'il refuse les
arrangements je crois qu'il a peut-être
par un avocat comme j'ai dit le gars de
general mills attendra pour faire son
offre officielle que cette histoire soit
réglée alors non ok ben t'en fais pas
c'était peut-être juste essayé de faire
son numéro habituel c'est ce qui fait
tout le temps et ensuite il sera dossier
et ça c'était avec sa paire de couilles
je vais lui parler
ok mais surtout n'attend pas trop
enjoy je suis déjà en retard et j'étais
presque moquée knighton je suis déjà en
retard tu as un nouveau garçon piscine
je les ai vus aujourd'hui comment il est
on a l'intention de changer le nom je
dois tout de suite aller quoi tu parle
d'hier c'est bien ça le garçon piscine
c'était pas aujourd'hui c'était bien
hier non aujourd'hui nouveaux gars de
quoi ils allèrent bas il est blond il a
peut-être cette taille un joli garçon
ouais je lis garçon a fait les affaires
comment alors qu'il bien sûr que tu as
vu le garçon piscine aujourd'hui et non
hier aucun doute non il n'ya pas de
doute c'était aujourd'hui je suis passé
pour dîner hier j'étais à une super
conférence sur les ventes
ce gars parler sans arrêt et qu'est ce
que tu dirais si j'allais te rejoindre
chez toi et tu me donnes el-cheikh
[Musique]
un nuage d'abeilles alors est ce que ces
braves
ouais qu'est ce que tu fous t'es chez
moi aujourd'hui oh rien du tout tu fous
pas de l'accueil écoutez vous en faites
pas d'accord je vous changera rien ce
coup là encore couché avec ma femme je
me suis dit on l'a déjà fait une fois
alors qu'est ce que ça peut faire un
et puis je vous changera rien school tu
me cherches rien tu vas me charger le
prix et moi je te perds et parce que tu
vas pas coucher avec ma femme pour rien
au quai de ma maison
encore une fois je ne serai pas jourdier
hockey est ce que tu veux qu'on sorte je
sais pas ou pour s acheter des chips ou
une pizza
j'ai une rencontre de travail je dois y
aller le groupe de rory jouer le mans
boyer
[Musique]
k
est-ce que vous de ce qui vous revient
le droit à merouana joad l'heure le
beagle c'est l'église
c'est du délire j'arrive pas à croire
que ma femme est couché avec ce gars là
a dit que ça ne dérangeait pas du tout
là je crois que j'ai parlé trop vite
il l'a séduite si rapidement c'est ça
que je digère pas d'être bien que je
suis nul au lit c'est pas du tout ta
faute tu avais dit mon ami brad c'était
tout un grand séducteur
je suis désolé si chérie ça ira ça ira
faut croire que tu as raison toutes les
femmes disent que ça leur est égal à
l'apparence qu'elle cherche un gars
brillant et amusant et ils finissent
toujours par rigoler avec le gars qui
est séduisant mais crétins avec qui je
t'ai pas dit ce pur est revenu chez moi
aujourd'hui encore pourquoi pourquoi tu
crois ouais tu engages un gap pour
exécuter un boulot un jour et le
lendemain il revient fait un petit saut
sur ta femme pour y arriver il le fera
pas pour rien je lui ai dit que j'allais
payer
ah oui combien j'en sais rien ce serait
bien tu penses que je devrais contact et
brad pour mou 10% il facturait par la
suite ou si je vais devoir ou en disant
tout ça y paraît important on discutera
d'économie un autre jour on n'a qu'à
mettre ça de côté pour l'instant ça n'a
aucune importance
ce qui est important c'est que tu
devrais déjà être en train de téléphoner
à cindy la conscience tranquille
ben je sais pas elle est à la fête
écoute j'ai peut-être quelque chose
alain je veux plus de drogue écoute je
sais que j'ai charrier et que je suis un
personnage singulier mais je suis
sérieux en ce moment et ça c'est un vrai
conseil alors je veux que tu m'écoutes
tu dois essayer de fumée du pote c'est
de la drogue c'est pas de la drogue
c'est une fleur jaune qui a des
propriétés curatives le stress est un
assassin que je deviens parano quand je
fais du pote là c'est en fait juste un
type tu sais ce que tu devrais faire tu
devrais rencontrer mon ami oui c'est un
bon gars si lui qui matin et les
tranquillisants pour cheval
les habitants de l'atlantide ont rêvé à
l'homme le secret il y a dix mille ans
déjà des drogues qui ne donne pas là que
le pouvoir parce que je veux dire le
monde commence juste à utiliser c'est
cheap à la vénérer voilà comment on va
résoudre les problèmes modernes la
sagesse des anciens devant la wii c'est
un chaman
[Musique]
non j'aime moi je suis du genre poids
plume si tu as une bière ou bien un peu
de vin ça c'est pas me faire plaisir
il faut qu'il parle je deviens ok t'es
familier avec le graphique ce bang dont
a déjà utilisé avant demain ok mais ton
pouce et tu mets ton pouce droit ici sur
le carburateur
quand je te dirais que te laisser aller
je veux tu te laisses l'aller ok tu
laisse entrer l'air ok expire
je vous laisse tout ça les deux fermes
là avec moi de lumière dean expireront
expire mais tes lèvres lattier inspire
non non plus fort encore inspire
[Musique]
[Rires]
à
[Musique]
j'ai cru que quelques voulait me parler
et
[Musique]
bordel de merde t'as vu le regard qu'ils
avaient ré doigté parano quand et stone
joue le jeu j'aimerais appeler lafittois
oui quelle erreur d'appeler ses deux
filles et de les mettre à l'est ok 00h30
soit chez elle de quoi elle adhère hall
a les cheveux châtains et elle est
mignonne et on voit que c'est une fille
de la classe ouvrière
qu'est ce que tu veux dire
[Musique]
est-ce qu'elle a l'air
[ __ ]
[Musique]
je dirais que oui ce comme ça que je les
aime ouais j'espère ne pas l'arrivée
s'est occupé ce qu'elle est chez elle
même qui nos jours n'a pas l'appel en
attente
j'en ai pas d'appel en attendant touquet
je déteste les appels en attaque quand
je tombe sur un jeu de fausses quelqu'un
de tout moi
monténégro renault qu'est ce qui est
épars à nos côtés stone je déteste les
appels en attente
ok mon gars tu es trop stone j'ai
signalé numéro pour toi
tu sais pourquoi s'était occupé tout à
l'heure
ça c'est mon numéro
[Musique]
tu as fini pour tu veux que je sois
parano 1
tu vas me faire chialer
joëlle kiffer ici
1 je suis pas fier de toi alors on
dirait que je me bats avec la quatrième
roue du carrosse lévitation ça a été
cool plus rien
[Musique]
le cochon au monde du jouet les skis
savoir qu est ce qui t as tu viens je
vais bien c'est juste on m'a cassé la
gueule tu peux te rendormir celle qu'est
ce qui s'est passé le hangar robert
serry un vendeur toi mais tu dois aller
à l'hôpital pour qu'il garde les siens
je veux juste dormir cette hausse s qui
était certain que ça va tu as juste à
kata kété beaucoup de gens se font
casser la gueule tu sais faut pas s'en
faire à les bonnutiens est ce que tu
veux un peu de glace
j'ai tout ce qu'il faut salut joël brian
voudrais vous voir au bon dieu qu'est-ce
que vous avez au visage d'une portière
d'auto tu as eu le temps de rencontrer
step et retourne pas mais appelle merde
on a un problème il a vu un avocat joad
l'heure l'avocat qui s'occupe de lésions
corporelles qu'on voit sur les bancs aux
arrêts d'autobus il a une affreuse coupe
de cheveux il faut que tu vois ce gars
c'est une merde humaine
merde qu'est ce qui était arrivé j'ai
raté une marche joad leur oui et puis ça
peut être un vrai problème mais pour
espérer avoir et on va devoir embaucher
un peu personnel sine die sans bail
t'étais au courant qu'elle sorte avec
step
quoi tu peux croire ça ce thème oui
notre step un autre ils se sont même pas
rencontré ici mais dans une épicerie ou
un endroit ou si peu probable comme un
imbécile heureux de têtes brûlées comme
lui plus ramassé une fille comme cindy
c'est pas croyable si tu es d'accord et
ben je vais virer ha directoire pourquoi
battue c'est l'histoire du sac à main et
celle du porte-monnaie d'einstein
il faut que ce soit lui qui dit ça peut
être ne vire pas hector pourquoi et que
tu fais moi confiance là dessus ok c'est
une dit johnny je ne me sens pas très
bien je vais rentrer chez moi tout de
suite
on
fait chier [ __ ] de merde mais qu'est
ce que tu fais encore sur marie toi
attendez vous deviez pas être ici avant
au moins quatre heures qu'est ce que
vous avez au visage la même chose que tu
envisages oralair du mien si jamais en
fait ton visage aura l'air encore pire
que le mien écoute si je te revois
tournait encore autour de ma femme crois
moi sur parole je peux te garantir que
je te ferai arrêté pour suis email à
centrer écoutez moi je sais c'est votre
femme et le reste on s'en fout et vous
devez savoir que je crois qu'en seine
vous vous aimez ce que tu es stupide
obrad le crétin brown le stupide créteil
couillon tu crois qu'elle serait
amoureuse de toi tu sais rien du tout
elle
ok t'es rien qu'un petit gigolo de mer
de fendant et ça s'arrête là non je
crois que non alors tu crois que non tu
as déjà pensé qu'elle ignorait que je te
payer pour avoir du sexe avec elle a
songé à ça est-ce que ça a déjà traversé
ta cervelle de moineau
si je rentre chez moi il me raconte tout
ce que tu fais ça pour être payés alors
qu'est ce t'en penses ding ding
taisez vous vous ne dirai rien mais
alors regarde ça cattin non on nous
regarde ça attendez je vous en prie non
mais écoutez monsieur mois et votre
femme
on vit quelque chose de spécial alors ne
vous y ait rien je vous en prie ne
bougies rien mais tu sais que là on
parle de madame brad may maison bordel
ma piscine stupid créé non raccordés
oui je peux
[Applaudissements]
tout comme ans est le nouveau gars sont
piscine de quoi tu parles
je parle de quoi d'après toi est-ce
qu'il a bien brossés tout autour un
métier
est-ce qu'il a enlevé toutes les
feuilles d'ici on dirait qu'il y a
beaucoup de saletés
alors je pense qu'elle est creusé est
vraiment dégueulasse on oui c'est vrai
qu'il a négligé je crois qu'il a fait un
travail horrible et je crois qu'on
n'aura plus besoin de lui maintenant
est-ce que c'est clair ok sûr que ça va
hein joël et si on allait chez le
docteur tu voudrais de l'aspirine
merci tu veux tu être des raisins
[Musique]
salut steph je viens hockey lui c'est
mon demi-frère fils voilà on n'a rien
d'accord et ferme la porte désolé alors
comme ça tu sors avec cindy ouais
monsieur c'est ma petite amie
on va peut-être aussi se marier après
que toute cette histoire de poursuites
soient réglés statut devrait peut-être
être prudent avec un pourquoi s'est elle
a une mts écoute ce thème je sais pas
comment présenter ça mais tu vas
recevoir un très gros montants d'argent
une fois que tout sera réglé
tu dois être prudent avec l ol je sais
que elle a eu ses problèmes mais elle va
mieux et cette fille c'est la meilleure
chose qui me soit arrivée step je veux
surtout pas dire quoi faire mais je
voudrais juste que tu penses à ça ok si
tu veux pas notre arrangement que tu
continues tu as poursuite tu pourrait
pousser à la banqueroute la compagnie
beaucoup de gens perdront leur emploi et
beaucoup d'employés pourraient vraiment
diffusera ça m'inquiète pas ça moi je
peut botter le cul n'importe qui dans
cette campagne et brad hawpe peux pas je
suis désolé mais on doit arrêter de
faire ça pour quoi
parce que c'est pas bien et que je me
sens très mal et toi tu dois vraiment
nettoyés cette piscine mais
jamais j'ai ressenti ça pour personne
avant et puis je suis sorti avec des
canaux hockey écoute brad j'aime mon
mari oh oui je t'assure et ça eh bien
c'était une erreur je suis désolé je
sais pas ce qui m'a pris je m'ennuyais
j'étais frustré et je me trouvais pas
très joli mais on doit on doit arrêter
ça ça ça m'a fait réaliser que je
voulais que mon mariage fonctionne je
suis désolé ça veut pas dire qu'on va
plus voir ça un oui c'est exactement ce
que ça veut dire pourquoi à cause de
tout ce que je viens de te dire tu veux
l'entendre encore on se voit demain non
alors disons je dis non on se voit
vendredi et là tu dois t'en aller
je vais t'appeler demain ok ok ok on en
parlera une autre
tu es vraiment court était prêt 1
on rencontre l'avocat de step ou ses
avocats c'est aujourd'hui tout rappelle
tout de suite certes je devrais vous
virer tous les trois vous avez ri de moi
quand j'ai acheté cette pub aux arrêts
d'autobus mais step
c'est le saint graal s'il s'il avait
perdu sa paire de couilles on aurait dit
ouf c'est une bonne cause mais pas une
grande cause nous vous qui n'a pas de
couilles n'est pas un homme le jury ne
pourra jamais entrer dans la peau d'un
homme qui n'a pas de couilles c'est un
monstre
mais cet élan corp une couille plus
qu'une dans le jury il est encore à
l'homme et cette virilité
elle vient là par un film je vous lis
10e gala c'est la couille aux doors
leurs proches il balaie y salue je suis
jo à leur salut monsieur regardez tous
ces gens dans le bureau ce sont les gens
de chez gino s'ils sont pour vendre
l'usiné passer à la caisse une laisse
hélas sans travail je dois avoir une
part de cet argent mois ya que ça à
faire je travaille ici depuis genre deux
ans de la merde ces menteurs ouais je me
suis arraché de cussy rappelle-toi et or
je suis toujours dit que je m'arrache
est qu ici j'ai travaillé ici pendant 14
ans on aurait eu du travail jugé m en
claquant des doigts et chez gm alors
tous les employés sont des associés
c'est écrit sur l'étiquette qu'il porte
là j'ai pas l'intention de les
travailler chez gm hockey
gm ça me fait suer il vous faut faire de
l'exercice c'est vrai on pourrait
travailler à sa droite airlines veut pas
aller travailler à s'auto et ses singles
et ils te font faire le limbo ça c'est
malade ouais ouais toute la communauté
métal va speedlingua si on part et
pourront rien faire ici ils seront pas
capables de vendre cet atelier ouais
c'est pourquoi ce qu'on doit faire c'est
celle de tous allés en grève demandé des
actions de la compagnie avant qu'ils
rendent si john roberts c'est qu'on est
en grève
boudreau
achetez l'endroit avant que la grêle
soir et et c'est pour ça que joël hemery
devons pouvoir nous donner des actions
ouais il faut agir vrai on va en grève
j'ai jamais arrêter de vous dire ça nous
avons tout envisagée est la seule façon
ne serait-ce que d'envisager un
arrangement serait de s'accorder avec
les chiffres au bas de la page 18 tout
le monde voit où ça coûte
croyez-nous monsieur hadler on n'a pas
assez d'argent comptant sachets sûr que
non mais si vous les kids et toutes vos
actions les biens immobiliers les
équipes et pour vous est-ce que vous
riez moi c'est la banqueroute j'ai
plusieurs fois ci de prévenir jouer
écouter si vous croyez que je vais ainsi
me séparer de cette compagnie que j'ai
construite à la ligue en quoi cette île
séparée de ses testicules
qu'en dites vous mais je suis prêt à
passionne d'accord nous allons
abandonner les charges tout de suite si
vous venez ici et mettez vos testicules
juste aimé s'est refermé cette porte
assez allez-y on peut s'entendre dans
cette cause est dire qu on est quittes
j'abandonnerai les charges tout de suite
si vous laissez m vous couilles dans
cette porte parce que c'est ce qui est
arrivé à mon client
ouais aucun doute c'est les quatre
généraux maires mais sentant pleine
négociation rien qu'à les voir qu'est-ce
qu'on fait alors une fois payé moi ils
vont reprendre maillot ils ont déjà fait
une fois on doit agir vite
ils sont peut-être sur le point de
signer mais et nous il nous restera plus
rien ce mandat courait on aura plus de
travail c'est violent c'est très
possible
ouais on doit faire une sortie c'est ça
qu'on doit faire d'accord alors qui me
suit on doit leur montrer via la force
c'est notre championne et elle est venue
brouiller aller en avant tout
je pense qu'on doit faire mais je
défendrai gentiment ladite somme à
condition que vous alliez à l'instant de
même à la porte et la refermer sur celle
de mes testicules dans cette porte je
veux que vous soyez raisonnable nous ne
va pas dire si vous allez tout va
écraser vos données 'core' dans cette
[ __ ] à porte
excusez moi que vous venez un besoin
reprendre nos esprits donner à tous une
petite minute
j'en ai assez entendu moi je rentre
ouais quoi quoi un coin de la joël un
bain c'est que quand on se disait qu on
était là bon on se disait que mme anne
marie a su nous ouvrir les yeux
vous êtes en train de signer avec
janeiro mais on s'est dit que disons
qu'on l'examiné on se disait tu comme
une tête qu'on voulait notre part mais
aussi et alors on a décidé de ce que
tout le monde a décidé c'est que rien en
fait ben alors on va on va les arrête
vous voulez votre pas c'est ça même si
c'est correct
et pourquoi pas tout la foutue compagnie
tant qu'à y être vous l'avez je vous la
donne la compagnie vous la faites rouler
hockey tout le monde est responsable à
partir de maintenant m'ont réveillé la
courroie le remplacement du convoyeur et
la poursuite civile
allez voir à de leur hockey tels qui
ferma la porte sur beaucoup il mais au
moins vous serez le patron hockey yahoo
alors c'est bon quoi j'allais dire autre
chose
et toi tu m'as coupe et couture elle
j'ai quelque chose à apprendre comment
gérer ça tu étais très occupé à ton
travail et c'est depuis plusieurs années
j'ai commencé à travailler de la maison
mais c'était pas je ne sais pas
peut-être quelques je me sentais pas
attirante à plus de garçons piscine
c'est ce à quoi
c'est ça que tu essaies de me dire un
baiser avec brave qu'un cours moi
j'étais au courant je les engage et je
sais qu'il a engagées mais comme un
testing est gelée pas engagées pour
nettoyer la piscine jeux les engagés
pour qu'il touche alt wah wah attend
pourquoi je les engagés pour qu'il a une
aventure avec toi pour que je puisse en
avoir une moi aussi ça me sentir
coupable mais j'étais vraiment sous mais
j'avais pris une sorte de
tranquillisants pour cheveux raides a
été payé quoi que tu as payé bras tout
ce temps là mais c'est pas vrai les 15 x
15 x 15 x seigneur mais est-ce qui
s'écoulait quinze jours c'est incroyable
mais comment tu arrive encore à
t'asseoir attends tu voulais avoir une
aventure avec une autre femme homme oui
mais je n'ai pas fait mais je le ferais
tu m'en parler c'était mon intention
mais écoute din din m'a fait prendre une
pilule vrai [ __ ] je suis sa nourrice
mambé suzie techniquement gérer a fait
aurait pu lui dire non merci on a tous
larre et à la rose il n'avait pas engagé
quand on vous attraper c'est rare que
vous aurez la porte n'était on n'a
vraiment pas le temps je m'en vais je
pourrait repasser quand d'après toi je
l'ignorent j'ai lignards tu vois c'est
un petit peu revenir demain ok oui
quelle heure je ligne hors tac à passer
de mains ok ok oui est ce que tu
pourrais avoir fait le chèque ce serait
bien gentil le total et 110 oui ça c'est
pour 2 55 dollars par assiette à tous la
porte
[Musique]
joël salut et qu'est-ce que
comment saviez-vous que j'étais ici bas
je reste ici aussi j'ai cru devoir alors
est bien rentré désolé vous voulez vous
quelque chose à boire
j'ai dit soda non merci écoutez je suis
désolé de ce qui est arrivé avec coulis
il devient cinglé c'est pour ça que j'ai
décidé de partir assoyez vous c'est le
sac à main de marie le sac à main là
c'est celui mari non c'est mon sac à
main alors comment ça se passe à l'
usine comment va tout le monde ça c'est
le sac ammann marie et tu la volée j'ai
raison joël c'est mon sac
il peut sembler aussi un c'est tout et
qu il y en a des tonnes comme celui là
j'en ai jamais vu un autre dans gens là
où un autre toutou dans un [ __ ] de
tutu alors qu'est ce que tu fous avec
step
c'est à cause de toi qu'il poursuit la
compagnie est ce que tu as une idée des
efforts que j'ai dû faire pour monter
cette compagnie n'en a aucune idée tu
t'en fous tu peux y aller et je pense à
et si c'est vraiment ton sac à leurs
appels à police tu pourra leur dire que
je les volets hockey non j'y repense je
vais les appeler tout de suite il leur
dira que c'est que c'est toi qui l'avais
sauvé je vous en prie quoi je vous en
prie ne faites pas ça je suis en
probation ici maredj elle en prison pour
très très longtemps pour elle aurait dû
penser à ça avant de commencer à
dépouiller mes employés sans parier je
te promet de laisser ce thème tranquille
laissera tomber son action comment j'en
serai certain tu garderas le sac à main
si je laisse pas step tranquille et s'il
refuse d'abandonner son action qui
n'aura qu'à me faire arrêter et le
porte-monnaie de sylvia et la montre de
jim tu les as tu me donneras aussi
je crois que ça marche
ok je parie que les essences alimentaire
tange à m'intéresser c'est quoi l'idée
comment on y tue arriver là oui c'est
exactement de quoi je parle la
manipulation et les sanglots et je vais
pas tomber dans un piège oublie ça tu
ferais mieux ne pas faire semblant
ok parce que là tu vois je commence à me
sentir mal et où est ce que tu fais
semblant
[Musique]
non
je suis désolé écoute c'est que j'étais
juste curieux de savoir comment
quelqu'un pourrait en arriver là
bancaire
[Musique]
je suis désolé ok
ça valait t'en fais pas je voulais juste
savoir
[Musique]
séné c'est une des mères
copé
[Applaudissements]
m
ouais
la matinée qu'est-ce que tu parles de ça
et si nous on arrive en retard ou là des
problèmes
[Musique]
l'électeur n'a rien fait s'il dit qu'il
a volé
[Musique]
pour protéger cette attitude va vraiment
falloir qu'on aille à l'épicerie step ne
t'a pas appeler un ça fait trois jours
que cette cindy en profite aux camions
c'est bien qu'on doit dire ça la police
écoutez sera bientôt de retour
elle n'aurait jamais osé me voler ok
c'était la dernière bouteille de pepsi
devrait peut-être appelé domino et leur
demander de libérer du pepsi mais si
elle a pu piquer ton camion et qu'elle a
eu aucun accident alors qu'est ce que tu
crois pas un mot sur cindy sinon je te
défonce la grande face de rat à l'eau
salut salubre et ya stable qui veut te
voir
ouais un fait la rentrée il est dehors à
côté dès qu'il veut te rencontrer tout
seul pour une raison obscure du genre
d'homme à homme
j'en ai assez de devoir traiter avec
saddler la vérité ce que je veux que ça
redevienne comme c'était je veux
retourner travailler
c'est quand même je suis un travailleur
c'est ce que je fais le problème c'est
que si je vais fermer la compagnie plus
personne ne voudra m'engager après t'es
pas obligé de faire fermer la compagnie
mais et si j'abandonne la poursuit vous
vendez la compagnie la nouvelle compagne
eva il engage ment jamais un gars cac
une couille
ouais écoute je crois pas ce thème que
ça les intéresse vraiment nom de ce côté
là ça va je suis un homme qui travaille
tout comme toi ces jeux je fais des
essences mois et j'adore ça tu sais la
vanille cerise racine est il ya aussi
beaucoup de gens trouvent que c'est pas
super cool mais moi je crois que c'est
super cool
alors pourquoi je voudrais vendre tout
ça
je crois que j'ai juste été distrait par
dix les trocs les gigolos
[Musique]
tu comprends ce thème ce que je veux
dire à quoi je pense je pense à
peut-être pas vendre la compagnie mais
ça c'est si avait aucune charge et tu
sais ya l'argent de la compagnie
d'assurance au système qu'est ce que
t'en dit
mouais ça leur registre est à une
condition laquelle serait responsable de
section
[Musique]
restait la ville merci au caire que tout
le monde approche
écoutez moi
ok je veux vous dire que j'ai décidé de
ne pas vendre la compagnie d'accord et
au système est maintenant le responsable
de section
ce qui ne serait pas content on engage
paraît-il chez gm que les patrons chez
gm et ben ils seront pas qui vous êtes
et vous serez pas qu'ils sont ils sont
quelque part dans un grand bureau au
siège social
quant à ici c'est pas pareil vous avez
qu'à monter là haut pour me parler de
votre problème hook est terminée ok ce
thème à tout âge d'une vente du nom je
veux que je te conseille d'apprendre
leur nous ont trahis
et arriva bonjour je veux faire tout ça
j'aurais deux camps mais moi j'ai
travaillé plus
[Musique]
salut
vous devez sûrement avoir envie de me
botter q je voulais vous dire que je ne
verrai plus jamais su si vous n'avez pas
à vous en faire l amour tout ça ça doit
être pour ça qu'il vous a épousé reste
mon gars tu en as de la chance et je
m'excuse pour ce qui est arrivé
pourquoi es tu es tu si épris de fusil
toutes les filles courent après ouais
mais je veux si je leur ai jamais tu
l'as déjà eu au moins 15 fois
ouais elle ne m'aime pas alors c'est pas
pareil c'est juste que je voulais vous
dire mais tu l'as dit ça d'accord
je pensais à ça et j'ai abandonné mon
dernier boulot et je crois que je suis
pas mme excellent j cole ou alors est-ce
que vous pensez que je pourrais
travailler dans votre entreprise par
question que je te donne un boulon oui
c'est sûr
[Musique]
atteint passe au bureau pour remplir une
demain des regarderai ça cool c'est très
gentil
et voilà l'homme à la queue de pétain ça
tourne
ouais je commence à croire que c'était
une super de belle bêtise ah ouais je
sais bien que c'est ma faute ou tel bien
que c'est ta faute non c'est la tienne
bon beaucoup de blâme autour de cette
table
je crois qu'il ya des gens qui ne
devraient pas toucher aux drogues
joël je crois qu'une de ces personnes là
et oh merde pourquoi tu nettoies la
piscine toi-même nouveaux gars c'était
pas ça mais c'est ça sa part marché
c'est toujours dur de trouver des
employeurs ouais
et est ce que tu as eu la chance de
m'écrire chèque
il est hors de question qu'on assiste à
ces dîners hockey j'aurais souhaité que
vous me disiez avant que j'achète et
billets joël n'a jamais voulu y aller je
les dis aussi que ça avait l'air de vous
enthousiasmer même que leslie elle est
appelée pourtant parlé mais jamais a
retourné nos appels
j'ai déjà acheté les billets ils ne sont
pas remboursables
j'aurais souhaité que vous soyez plus
direct avec moi dans ce cas laisse moi
être direct avec toi d'accord nous quand
on dit des choses genre j'en sais rien
du tout où je suis pas sûr ou compte
claque la porte au visage la réponse est
non
pourquoi tu saisis pas ça vient je les
herbes paquet laisse moi être encore
plus direct avec toi ok mais tu n'es tu
vois tu nous fais suer s'est assis
direct on t'aime pas tu es triste tu
écoute jamais tu parles tout en tête au
jour dans notre jardin
j'ignore ce qu'assure son barbecue tous
les jours mais ça craint qu'il reste là
devant la cour était que ta radio de
voiture tu es le pire voisins au monde
qui nous ennuie et on se fout de toi
n'est deux sets assez direct samedi la
ferme
non
[Musique]
salut est-ce que ça va je crois bien que
je les tue et joël la dernière chose
qu'il a pu entendre c'était moi qui
gueulait après lui ouais ils en disaient
des choses
ouais cité sans arrêt à la fin j'ai dit
jean t mais c'est pas ta photo suzy
probable que ce soit une coïncidence qui
ca
je me sens coupable alors je dis allez
strict et je serai au dîner ce soir elle
a dit que n'étonnerait dit ravi alors
moi j'ai dit que j'irai aussi alors
qu'ils s'étaient cette femme avec qui tu
voulais avoir une aventure c'était juste
une une criminels récidivistes
c'était pas génial j'ai cru qu'elle
s'intéressait à tout ce qui était censé
tout le reste eh ouais je devrais savoir
que personne ne s'intéresse aux essences
je suis pas sûr tout ça c'est vrai vous
en vendez des tâches pense qu'il ya des
gens qui aiment ça
écoute je dois te mettre au courant
j'ai engagé brad j accorde tu me l'a dit
il rappelle toi tout la non désolé homme
je parle pas de sexe ou de piscine
je voulais dire que je les engage et l
usine pourquoi il est vraiment con way
je le sais ce que je vais dire hors
l'air bizarre mais je me sentais mal
pour les way
je suis aussi ma voiture et de ce côté
alors toi aussi tu seras au rotary club
moi je serai là si on devrait peut-être
prendre juste une voiture
oui
bonne idée
ses funérailles peuvent vraiment vous
savez l'année
et tu sais on regarde je me disais c'est
sûrement une des seules fois où je l'aï
vu aussi longtemps la bouche fermée
[Musique]
elle
et des mots
[Musique]
à
sa voix
allez c'est fini je suis pas l'allant et
c'est moi ménages
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'elle fout
si donc ça pour trouver des fous du
cicar par ici
m
[Musique]
oakley monsieur
le film a gun
d
[Musique]